NYPD Blue Star Austin majors has died he
was 27 years old
[Music]
reports that Austin died over the
weekend in Los Angeles while staying at
a homeless housing facility so far no
cause of death has been released but
according to the outlet their suspicions
Austin died from a fentanyl overdose and
no foul play is suspected ET has reached
out to Austin's Reps for comment and I
want you to be the first one to show
them how to throw a baseball because you
got a natural motion I do oh yeah Austin
was best known for his role as Theo on
the long-running police drama playing
the son of Dennis franza's character
Andy sipowicz what's wrong Daddy
[Music]
all right
I love you Daddy
[Music]
after the series wrapped in 2005 Austin
found roles on ER According to Jim and
How I Met Your Mother in a statement to
TMZ the actor's family says quote Austin
took great joy and pride in his acting
career calling him a loving artistic
brilliant and kind human being quote
Austin was the kind of son brother
grandson and nephew that made us proud
and we will miss him deeply
[Music]
foreign